Queste sono le tre posture standard che voi potete assumere ogni volta che è appropriato.
Quindi se ci sentiamo scomodi nella posizione seduta allora possiamo alzarci in piedi e restare
col respiro, continuando ad osservare ciò che sorge e passa.
Quindi quando invece facciamo la posizione, insomma la pratica camminata, allora scegliamo un percorso di 10 o 15 passi,
Cominciamo con la posizione in piedi e mettiamo l'attenzione sui piedi.
Così che per tutto il giorno, per la maggior parte del giorno, per una parte del giorno almeno, noi riusciamo a stare con il salire e scendere dell'addome o con il muoversi del piede, l'alzarsi e l'abbassarsi del piede.
Quindi sempre più consapevoli dei fenomeni che sorgono e che passano, che svaniscono.
e il terzo tipo di consapevolezza che facciamo solo quando vogliamo rilassarci ma non vogliamo perdere la nostra consapevolezza.
Ora, perché ci rilassiamo?
Quindi come mai diventiamo tesi?
Tesi, contratti.
Spero che non vi aspettiate una risposta da me.
Penso che troverete che è sempre perché stiamo cercando di raggiungere qualcosa.
Penso che scoprirete presto che il motivo è perché state cercando di ottenere qualcosa.
Può essere che senza che ne siamo coscienti noi stiamo cercando di raggiungere, ottenere un certo tipo di comprensione.
Quello che dobbiamo capire è che l'insight, quindi la visione profonda, avviene di per sé stessa, da sola, indipendentemente da noi.
Tutto ciò che noi possiamo fare è guardare.
E questo non vale solo per la meditazione, vale per tutto.
Se il tuo auto si scorda e tu apri la bonnetta, tutto ciò che puoi fare è guardare.
Se la macchina, la vostra macchina si rompe e voi aprite il copano, tutto quello che potete fare è guardare.
Può darsi che vediate qualcosa, può darsi di no.
A volte cercate di ottenere il risultato di vedere il vostro respiro o il vostro passo più chiaramente.
Ma se la visione non è chiara, la visione non è chiara.
Uno continua a guardare.
È come se siete su una montagna cercando di vedere un paesaggio e c'è della foschia.
Voi impegnerete molta energia cercando di far andare via la foschia.
Aspettate, la foschia se ne andrà.
Quindi la stessa cosa all'interno di noi, quando non riusciamo a vedere perché c'è questa
visione un po' offuscata non chiara è quello che noi dobbiamo osservare visione offuscata altre volte noi cerchiamo di concentrarci e questo ci rende molto tesi perché ci ricorda la scuola quindi
Quindi è più abile cercare di invece stimolare un senso di interesse.
Quando mai avete avuto problemi di concentrazione in caso in cui siete stati veramente interessati a qualcosa?
Quindi cercate di sviluppare continuamente dentro voi stessi questo interesse nello scoprire come siete fatti veramente.
Quindi ditevi tutte le volte che è necessario che voi non siete venuti qua per avere un sollievo psicologico.
Abbandonate ogni speranza di psicoterapia.
Abbandonate ogni speranza di sentirvi meglio fisicamente.
abbandonate ogni speranza che dopo una settimana voi possiate essere anche un po' più saggi qualsiasi obiettivo che va oltre questo momento presente corromperà inquinerà la vostra meditazione
Quindi dobbiamo sviluppare noi stessi questa fiducia che tutto ciò che dobbiamo fare è osservare e curare noi stessi.
Tutto si curerà.
Non suggerisco che le malattie si curino.
Quindi io non è che sto suggerendo che le malattie si cureranno.
Ma cambierà la vostra relazione con essa, con la malattia.
Se avete perso una gamba, avete perso una gamba.
Ma non necessariamente questo deve essere deprimente.
Quindi il nostro lavoro, se voi vi chiedete cosa devo fare, è sviluppare queste abilità di meditazione.
Le abilità, le competenze.
Quindi continuate a ricordarvi che tutto ciò che state facendo è essere consapevoli del sorgere e dello svanire, dell'andare via, del passare.
Se state meditando e vi sentite rigidire, che guardate in giù e siete rigidi, semplicemente rilassatevi.
E ricominciate da capo.
Conoscete tutti Fred Astaire e Ginger Rogers.
Però sono degli Arahats, degli Illuminati.
E io questo l'ho capito da una canzone che hanno cantato.
La canzone dice tiratevi su, datevi una bella spazzolata e ricominciate tutto da capo.
E questa è la pratica spirituale.
over and over and over and over and over until we come to the end ricominciare sempre da capo da capo da capo fino a quando non si arriva alla fine so we need patience and perseverance quindi ci serve pazienza e perseveranza yeah and this comes easy if we expect nothing e questo viene facilmente se non ci aspettiamo nulla yeah
Abbandonate ogni aspettativa.
Quindi abbiamo due tecniche.
La prima è il notare, registrare le cose, annotare, e la seconda è l'andare lentamente.
Quindi il problema principale è slegare e staccare questa intelligenza intuitiva dal pensiero, dal lato del pensare, dall'intelletto.
Noi crediamo di essere i nostri pensieri.
Noi pensiamo di essere ciò che pensiamo.
Io penso, quindi sono.
Quindi noi adesso dobbiamo fare un piccolo scherzo alla mente.
Noi riduciamo l'intelletto a una sola parola.
Quindi noi riduciamo l'intelletto ad un'unica parola.
Uno o due.
In inglese è più facile.
Sollevare, avanzare, abbassare.
Potete anche ridurre le vostre frasi solo a due parole.
In piedi invece che stare in piedi.
Perché in inglese c'è una parola sola.
Quindi lo scopo è quello di contenere il pensiero in una singola parola.
E l'attenzione, che è la tua intelligenza, è messa sulla sensazione o sul sentimento.
E la vostra attenzione che è questa intelligenza intuitiva è sulla sensazione.
Cosicché queste sensazioni diventano sempre più chiare.
E questa parola diventa sempre più delicata e svanisce, recede.
se la parola, soprattutto per chi è nuovo a questa pratica, se la parola sembra essere tutto questo dimostra al meditatore quanto loro siano connessi, collegati con il pensiero
il problema con il pensiero è che non vi permetterà di vedere l'oggetto chiaramente quando dico pensiero intendo anche immagine quando guardo questa bellina guardo con tutta la mia storia di belline
Mentre io guardo questa campana io la sto guardando con tutta la mia storia di campane.
Quindi io la sto confrontando e la sto percependo con tutta la mia esperienza del passato.
Non riesco a vedere questa campana di per sé stessa.
Io deposito continuamente su questa campana la mia esperienza passata di campana o di campane passate.
Quindi la mia esperienza passata che è intrappolata nella mente, nei pensieri, immagini, crea una distorsione del mondo reale.
Questo diventa evidente nei nostri pregiudizi culturali, sessuali.
ma questo lavora anche a livello delle semplici percezioni rest your eye on the flower
domani quando camminerete intorno al centro guardate un fiore e rimanete sul fiore e dite semplicemente guardare comincerete a percepire il fiore come non l'avete mai visto prima ho un piccolo trucco che potrebbe funzionare per voi
Se guardate il palmo della vostra mano, continuate a dire guardare, guardare, vedete come la mente la percepisce.
Vedete come l'occhio percepisce forma, creci, colore?
Vedete come l'occhio percepisce la forma, le pieghe, il colore?
Non dovete provare.
Viene naturale al processo del vedere.
Avete veramente guardato nel palmo della vostra mano prima d'ora?
Stranger?
Quindi questo è ciò che dobbiamo fare con qualsiasi cosa che sorge all'interno del corpo, del cuore e della mente.
Quindi questa parola, etichetta, servirà a estrapolare l'intelligenza dalla confusione del pensiero e immagine.
Quindi dobbiamo continuare a fare un esercizio molto gentile, solo un esercizio gentile.
Ora, c'è una connessione tra il pensare e questa intelligenza intuitiva.
E utilizzando una parola notabile, come guardare, guardare, sta aiutando questa intelligenza a guardare.
e quindi usando questa etichetta mentale come guardare guardare si aiuta questa intelligenza intuitiva a guardare è come se spingesse questa qualità del guardare guardare guardare sentire sentire
Quindi quel notare deve essere deliberato, intenzionale.
Se non lo è diventa allora un mantra.
quindi il meditatore fa esperienza del salire, scendere, toccare e la mente poi divaga da Acapulco e quando tornate la mente sta ancora dicendo salire, scendere, toccare possiamo sviluppare qualsiasi abitudine che vogliamo
E possiamo addestrare la mente a continuare a dire, salire, scendere, toccare.
Ma qui non c'è nessuna intelligenza.
Nulla da imparare.
Una completa perdita di tempo.
Quindi la notazione deve essere deliberata e ci deve essere l'esercizio
Quindi questo notare deve essere intenzionale, ci deve essere lo sforzo, questo sforzo delicato di vedere, di osservare, chiaramente.
Quindi l'atteggiamento da tenere è uno di curiosità.
Avete notato come un gatto osserva qualcosa con quella curiosità del voler conoscere.
E questa è la curiosità, la curiosità di un bambino.
E viene da una posizione del non sapere.
Questa posizione del non sapere si raggiunge quando noi smettiamo di pensare e di immaginare.
quindi lo sforzo di arrivare a questo punto del non conoscere non è uno sforzo per ottenere qualcosa ma è uno sforzo di lasciare andare dobbiamo depositare i nostri bagagli ora per rendere ancora più chiaro questa visione spostiamo tutto
Quindi per rendere questo modo di vedere, questa visione, per vedere ancora più chiaramente, noi rallentiamo.
Quindi si vedono in quei documentari della natura quando un cita, che sarebbe un cita, si dice anche in italiano, un leopardo, quando corre...
Quando si vede il rallentatore, allora si vede tutto come fosse un balletto, no?
Di solito per noi, quando lo vediamo correre, è solo un'immagine offuscata, veloce.
E' solo quando si vede tutto il rallentatore che si vede esattamente come una rana, per esempio, cattura una mosca.
Cattura la mosca sopra la lingua o sotto?
Sotto.
Questa è una grande scoperta.
Quindi se riusciamo a rallentare, rallentare tutto molto, riusciamo a vedere chiaramente come le cose funzionano.
La domanda principale del Buddha non è perché.
Quindi la domanda chiave del Buddha non è perché.
Perché siamo esseri umani?
Perché soffriamo?
La domanda è come.
Quindi noi stiamo indagando su come noi creiamo questo mondo, come noi stessi creiamo questo mondo.
Come lo facciamo e com'è che sbagliamo?
Se noi capiamo, vediamo come, si spera che non lo facciamo di nuovo.
Spero che troviamo un modo di essere nel mondo che non crea così molti problemi per noi stessi.
Quindi troveremo un modo di stare in questo mondo senza creare troppi problemi a noi stessi.
Senza pensare a tutti gli altri, senza parlare di tutti gli altri.
Quindi cercate di andare lentamente, per chi è nuovo può richiedere un po' di tempo.
E continuerò a ricordarvelo.
In un modo delicato ma persistente.
Ora, nelle sedi...
Oh, solo una cosa.
Non bisogna andare spesso tutto il tempo.
Bisogna essere consapevole, come ad esempio in mattina quando stai lavandosi, quindi lavandosi normalmente.
non è che dovete andare lentamente sempre per esempio al mattino quando dovete lavarvi o liberare il bagno a patto nono al vento ma siccome stiamo tutti praticando il metodo Mahasi anche quando per esempio prendiamo il cibo e siamo in coda possiamo tutti rallentare ma non lo farei troppo lentamente
ma non lo farei troppo lentamente ci sono stati dei casi in cui dei meditatori affamati hanno accoltellato i meditatori in coda davanti a loro in coda ma mentre mangiamo allora qui possiamo andare molto lentamente ma parlerò di questo domani mattina
Nella fine della seduta io vi chiederò di riflettere sulla seduta.
Quindi alla fine della sessione seduta noi possiamo permettere ad alcuni ricordi di sorgere, ricordi relativi a quella seduta.
Per esempio potremmo ricordarci che per tutta la seduta noi stavamo cercando di stare svegli.
E quindi possiamo riflettere riguardo quanto io sono stato abile a cercare di stare sveglio.
Quindi ho aperto gli occhi, mi sono alzato, mi sono di nuovo seduto.
Cioè cosa ho fatto per tenermi sveglio?
Potevo essere più abile?
Avrei potuto essere più abile?
E questo modo di riflettere ci rende più abili.
E quindi ci prendiamo un piccolo impegno con noi stessi, la prossima volta che succede sarò più veloce ad aprire gli occhi, ad alzarmi e così via.
E questo va distinto dal giudicarsi.
Se vi sentite dire a voi stessi io sono senza speranza, non ce la faccio, non riesco.
Notate giudicare, giudicare.
E non ci credete.
La mente è una bugiarda.
Quindi dopo ogni seduta c'è questo momento in cui si ricorda della fiducia.
appunto dell'esperienza della seduta, siamo stati pigri oppure abbiamo messo troppo sforzo.
E poi questo impegno che se dovesse succedere un'altra volta sarò un po' più furbo.
Un po' più clever.
Un'altra cosa che potrebbe esservi utile è la ripetizione.
Quindi se vi trovate a correre su per le scale, fermatevi.
Tornate giù e cominciate di nuovo.
Intending to walk slowly.
This is like at school when we had to do corrections.
And finally...
E l'ultima cosa è non mischiate, mescolate i sistemi, le tecniche, penso.
E se lo fate, se lo state facendo, diteglielo.
Perché così io potrò capire perché vi state comportando in quel modo.
Ci sono tanti sistemi di meditazione, molte tecniche.
E ci sono tante tecniche anche nelle diverse tradizioni zen, tibetana, theravada.
Ma ogni sistema ha i suoi controlli e balance.
Ogni sistema, ogni tecnica ha il suo sistema di equilibri, di controlli e equilibri.
Quindi è importante che voi stiate con un sistema, state sicuri che quello funzioni per voi.
Nelle interviste il mio interesse principale è capire come voi state mantenendo la consapevolezza.
Perché se una persona sta facendo la pratica nel modo corretto tutto verrà da sé.
Io non devo fare nulla.
È il lavoro più facile che io abbia mai avuto.
Quindi chiuderemo qui la serata e io farò una piccola meditazione
Sì, sulle regole di questo foglio avrete il discorso sull'eventuale salameo.
E potete imparare il chant con me se volete, o usatelo come occasione per sviluppare la vostra metà.
È importante che noi ci rendiamo conto che stiamo facendo tutto questo anche per il beneficio di tutti gli esseri viventi.
Quando noi cambiamo, tutto il mondo cambia.
Quindi è importante che noi alla fine della nostra giornata offriamo i nostri meriti al di fuori, quindi alle altre persone.
Può essere a un individuo oppure a tutti gli esseri o a tutti e due.
quindi non importa se noi pensiamo effettivamente di influenzare di avere qualche effetto su queste persone quello che facciamo è sviluppare un atteggiamento di generosità
Quindi sta a voi scegliere se volete cantare o recitare insieme a me, oppure se scegliete questa recitazione come...
Un veicolo per trasferire il vostro amore verso gli altri.
Oppure potete portare alla vostra mente delle persone, degli individui e offrirgli dei buoni auspici.
Possiate stare bene e essere felici.
Qualcosa di semplice.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassam Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassam Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassam
karaniyam gattaku salena, yantam santam padam gabisame ca, sako uju ca suju ca, suvaco ca samudu anati mani, santu sako ca subharo ca,
hapa kicchocca salahu kavuti, santendriocca nipakocca, hapa gabokule suananugido, na cakudang samacare kenci, ye na vinyupare upavadeyom,
Sukhino vakemino hantu sabhe satabhavantu sukhi tatha ye keci panabhutati tasavattavarava anavasesa digavaye mahantava majimarasakanukatula
Dita vā ye vā adhita ye cādure vā santi āvidure bhūtā vā sambhāvezi vā sābe sātā bhāvantu sukhi tātā nā paroparāṅ nīkubhata nā tīmāññata kathā cīneṃ kencī
VIA ROSANA PATIGASANYAS NANYAMANYASA DUKANG ICHEYA MATAYATANIYANG PUTANGAYUSA EKAPUTANGANURAKE EVAMPISABHABHUTESU MANASAMBHAVAYE APARIMANAM
METENCHA SABHALOKASMIN MANASAMBHAVAYE APARIMANAM UDANGA DOCCHATIRIYANCHA ASAMPATHANGA VERANGASAPATHAM TITANCHARANNISINOWA SAYANOVAYAVATASAVIGATAMIDO
etam satim adhiteya brahmam etam viharam vidamahu dithin ca anupagama silava dasanena sampano kamesu vinaya gedam nahi jadu gabaseyam punare titi
Tutti gli esseri possono essere felici, al sicuro.
Tutti gli esseri possono stare bene.
Tutti gli esseri possono essere felici.
Tutti gli esseri possono vivere appagati e in pace nel mondo.
Sāve sātā sukītā hantu Sāve sātā sukītā hantu Sāve sātā sukītā hantu Sādhu sādhu
quindi ora è ora di andare a dormire e da questo punto fino a quando andiamo a dormire è anche parte della nostra pratica dobbiamo ridurre qualsiasi senso di hierarchia
Siedersi è più importante di camminare, camminare è più importante dell'andare a letto.
Ogni momento deve essere intenzionale e consapevole.
E con cura.
è con cura quindi quando aprite una porta intende, è intenzione di aprire la porta muovere, muovere toccare, toccare sentite il metallo comunicate con il metallo
girate la maniglia sentendo la pressione tirare, tirare o spingere, spingere e via di seguito quindi state effettivamente comunicando con la molla quindi non è questo
quindi la porta bisogna comunicare con la porta e questo vale per ogni cosa che fate comunicate tornate al corpo alle sensazioni le sensazioni solo arrivano nel momento presente
Le sensazioni sorgono solo nel momento presente.
Non puoi avere una sensazione ieri.
Quindi se conoscete la sensazione dovete essere per forza nel momento presente.
Quando alla fine siete sdraiati proni sul letto mettete l'attenzione sul respiro
Se vi sentite un po' agitati potete usare qualche bella frase tipo che tutti gli esseri possano essere felici.
Fate questa pratica, li metta dal cuore.
Questo ammorbidisce la mente e vi addormenterete.
Se vi sentite molto agitati e non potete dormire
se siete molto agitati e non riuscite a dormire potete provare questo prendete una posizione che si accomoda e rifiutatevi di muovervi rifiutatevi di muovervi e vedrete che l'energia girerà
E vi sveglierete domani mattina.
Perché se vi muovete voi date potere, forza al sistema.
Vi girate, vi rigirate.
Appena prima di addormentarvi prendete una convinta decisione di svegliarvi con la campana.
Dormite in pace.